so by the way after i did the rogan
episode i you know
how much i love
and and value journalists
because they write about our world
and it's so important and many of the
a few articles are written about me
who's this tim doe
he says he sold subprime mortgages and
his mother's a schizophrenic
it's like the the level of research they
do is like nothing it's like
yeah that's in a five-minute set you can
find online well done
um and so and then some of them are like
he's made
controversial comments and by the way
these aren't journalists let me correct
myself
there's like seven journalists in
america that's why everyone's like trump
hates journalists
there are no journal they don't exist
they're not real they're like santy
claus
they're not a thing okay there's a few
of them
very few of them who actually cultivate
sources
break story they did not happen
the majority of these people are
stenographers they write things they
hear they hear gangnam
and then they type it and they write
listicles and
buzzfeed one of them was like the top 10
craziest things you hear from the rogan
alex jones
this is not journalism it is
something else entirely um and then of
course there are and this is very very
funny
people who put the words comedy and
journalist in one job title
i'm a comedy journalist my
beat is people that make
sillies i write about them
and some of these people like they'll be
like tim dillon's made
controversial statements about the
kenosha
shooting the kyle rittenhouse and the
and none of
and then i read what's supposedly
controversial
and it's like tim dillon said there was
looting and right and it's like
no objective reality
has said that
i have repeated it because i have ears
and eyes and
senses and i don't go at it with like
the need to
slant i just go i'm watching tv
i'm watching things burn i'm
watching people throw things through
windows
what would i call that if i had to
destroy
and whatever it is what it is fine when
i [ __ ]
i'm not saying people shouldn't be
pissed i get it
you know but this idea that like i uh oh
y'all cars made some controversy and the
controversial statement i saw was that
the
the written house guy was being chased i
was being chased i think somebody and i
somebody had a gun or whatever like and
again i saw the video i saw the video
and i said what i saw in the video
and then they take all these things out
of context that are very very funny
i made some very funny statements about
that very very funny about the family
you know the written houses
i said they're a bit off and they're
like he said they're a bit
like it's it's it's clearly humor and
these people don't have a sense of humor
all these tech journalists these tech
journalists these women or
not sorry sorry sorry these entities
with you know green hair and a usb
port for a [ __ ] are are
you know these miserable people they're
miserable
they're unhappy they're unhappy and it's
my
fault it's my fault you're miserable
and they and then i look and twitter
many of them have blocked me they've
already blocked me and i'm like what am
i
what did i do what did i do did i shoot
anyone
did i go to the protest with the gun
with my mother
i don't just see my family during good
times i didn't grab my family and say
let's all get in the van go to the
protest
i'm commentating on it tim dylan get it
up here get up
google me and see let's get this article
up it's it's absurd
tim dillon made uh do google tim dillon
kenosha
how great is how fun has my life become
yeah go to me what is this meow is it
mia
i guess this is the one joe rogan puts
alex jones tim dillon on his podcast
internet angry he featured anti-vaxxer
during pandemic keep going down
and then
yeah and then they but who is tim dillon
he owes a podcast called tim dylan's
going to hell that has not been the name
of the podcast for years
some of his comments during the black
lives matter protest have received sharp
criticism
from who case in point in the aftermath
of the shooting
in kenosha wisconsin in late august
commenting on armed civilians dylan had
said quote
when the police are defunded abolished
this will be the scene in many major
cities militias fighting each other on
the street
[Music]
well what do you think the scene will be
compliance do you think everybody i mean
what
i mean how dumb are these people so keep
going down then they find a tweet
where i say a logical rational thing
so with these two guests on board it is
only likely that people will criticize
rogue's decision to host some
one twitter user said wtf is wrong with
him
ugh there was a time years ago and his
podcast had some interesting
thought-provoking episodes now it's just
crazy town
oh it wasn't thought-provoking aren't
you having thoughts right now
aren't you having thoughts it's not
thought-provoking you went on twitter
and started writing about it apparently
you were provoked
and you were having thoughts come on
it's there's there's there's a children
in the country
i mean we don't deserve a government or
our future and we and
here's the good news we probably won't
have one um
it's it's childish
we can officially count his show among
the most dangerous propaganda outlets in
the guy
by the way guarantee that person is a
podcast is not doing well
anyone that's really mad at this let's
let's really unpack the problem
by the way all of these people are
have to here's it let's break this down
for a minute you know i never talk about
comedy but let me get in here for a
minute
let me get in here for a minute comedy
is a haven for the mentally ill
there is actually very little comedy the
majority of comedy and comedians
are are mentally ill people they're sick
including me the difference is that i'm
funny
you see if i was sick and not
funny i'd be angry because i'd be like
well i'm sick
and i'm not funny like i have these
obsessions and i'm crazy and everybody
knows
bloody blue and and i talk about all
this [ __ ]
and and it's funny and i find a way to
make it funny and that's how i survive
on this planet right
but if i didn't have the converter if i
wasn't able to make it funny a la many
of the people i know
i would be in trouble and many of these
people are troubled and then i would
look at funny people and look at
successful people and i'd be in a blind
rage which is where these people live
they've wasted their entire life i hate
using a hack example
i hate using a hack example i'm going to
use a dumb hack example again that i've
used a million times
but if i showed up every day to
ford modeling agency someone there would
have to sit me down and go
explain to us why you think this is
going to work
explain to us what you're seeing in the
world
that makes you think that we want a
blotchy
overweight irishman in any of our ad
we want mediterranean muscle baby
black white whatever don't care why do
you
think this is going to work nowhere in
our in our pre
do we want redness occasional
redness unexplained redness
i don't even know why it happens i just
get red
in parts of my body my skin my emotions
bleed out of my skin
these people are going to ford modeling
it and i don't even know who this is and
i'm sure they're not a horrible person
and would
i don't care this is not like beefs and
feuds it doesn't matter to me
maybe they are funny no but let's not
leave this up i don't want to [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] article
let's let's get something fun up like a
jack-o'-lantern
but the whole thing here is be very very
very
be very honest here
is a little bit of the anger jealousy
that joe has done something that none of
these people were able to do
these people think they're intelligent
and they're smart
and and they're too good to have the
biggest podcast in the world they're too
smart
they're too smart to have the biggest
podcast in the world
what a what a take they're too good for
success me and mullen used to talk about
that all the time
people are too good to succeed they're
too funny
to perform in front of other people
they're too good so the rage that these
people live with all
all the time they're just angry they're
just very very angry that they've
dedicated their life
to something that hasn't worked out and
here's the quest
here's the quest who told you
to do that who
told you that that was a good idea i bet
no one did no when you go to
thanksgiving you know i'm a comedian
your family goes thanks
great peel the potato no one cares
imagine going to your family going i'm a
comedy journalist
this is a million people who want to be
chapel trap house you're not
they are very very funny they're
hilarious whatever you think about their
chat and they talk [ __ ] about everybody
but they're very funny you know i i
don't even know who they are
but whatever they mullin live with one
of them the skinny woman with the cat
i i think they're good i they're funny
and then there's 90 million other people
and then the red people are funny too
red uh the the the
communist [ __ ] i don't know whatever
that show is scary they're good too
they're funny right some of them i don't
know but occasionally i've heard things
like i like it
uh whatever i don't mind i don't mind a
little marxism baby
but then there's 90 million [ __ ]
people that aren't funny
that are just angry because things are
unfair
that um oh yes things are not good
do i come out here every week and go
it's it's getting better and
lives what am i ben shapiro well
actually folks it's actually not as bad
as you think
no i think i'm pretty honest about how
[ __ ] we are
and if you think that the reason we're
[ __ ] is alex jones man are you out to
[ __ ] lunch how lucky would we be
how lucky would we be if the biggest
problem in this country was some
it's like a conspiracy guy in texas
that's crazy
the problems are so institutional so
deep rooted
that this selective rage and a
successful podcast
having a guy on a broadcaster and then
fact checking him in real [ __ ] time
i mean that's crazy that you would get
so angry about that
but it's it's really about just the rick
because they never were cool
they just want to be they just want to
throw eggs with johnny and alfred
well i don't know there johnny came to
see me in west palm beach by the way
thank you for coming i didn't let him in
the green room as a covenant
i love that now because it covered i got
no one could come in the green room the
manager can't talk to me because they're
covered
uh uh uh my f no i don't have a next of
kin clove it
go to the doctor that you're going to
fill out that next to ken i just write
covered they're all dead
but did everybody wants to throw eggs
everybody wants to to
put shaving cream on the car it's what
it is
people aren't thinkers these people
aren't
actualized human beings they want to hug
they want someone to go you're you
matter you're
valid you you you're you're
you should be here and i mean on earth
hey you should be here on this planet
that's all these people are trying to do
and
don't think anything of it
you think alex jones is changing minds
on the joe rogan experience
you think my aunt who's a hardcore biden
voter is gonna go well
you know alex made a good point about
inter-dimensional
uh lizards so i think i'm going to go in
there and vote red
no this whole thing of people
influencing each other it's like
there's such a small sliver of people
that can even be influenced
you know and alex is more is a complex
guy
smart guy made some mistakes very clear
but this whole blind rage that everybody
flies into every time joe has a
conversation
with people they don't like is is
embarrassing i'm embarrassed for a lot
of these people i'm like
why have you not like
figured out that you're the entire
problem the entire reason you know the
red scare at steve bannon on people went
nuts they got mad
they got angry why why
they're having a conversation what's
dangerous about having a conversation
i don't understand it's but it goes back
to just social
you know i get i get it's it's you learn
all those lessons young if you pay
attention you learn all those lessons
young
you people just want to be uh accepted
they want to accept each other they just
want to be there and
all these people just want to be a
revolution they just want to it's not
it's got to matter right
it's got to matter can all be shitty job
interviews in panera let me throw a
brick through the [ __ ] louis vuitton
and let's do a little revolution i'm
bored
can't all be broccoli and cheese soup on
the way to some hell
i want a revolution i want to i want to
live in historic times
i want to do something well then do
something do something actually
something
and i'm not saying you know don't
[ __ ] i know their comfort is showing